[Music]
hey tom hey katie
hi how are you oh my god may i just say
i have never seen anything like this oh
my god
i just have to stop a minute oprah was
so blown away by tom's 320 acre ranch
during her famous visit
that she actually bought her own lodge
nearby yeah
we get it oh i love a great kitchen man
yeah
this is the heart of the house this is
it this is the soul
right here cruz's colorado estate was
custom built for privacy
look at your view from the kitchen
though yeah this is great this is great
the driveway a mile long the main house
is 10
000 square feet with seven bedrooms and
nine bathrooms
the price tag just under 40 million at
39.5
of course you can't put a price tag on
the cruise cachet
and the ranch's spot in pop culture
history when you saw it for the first
time what did you think
i was just blown away yeah i mean just
driving up the
the road to get here usually it's like
nothing i've ever seen people like
nothing i've ever
seen i couldn't wait to show her this is
where baby suri had her first photo
shoot back in 2006
when the then happy family was on the
cover of vanity fair
when oprah visited katie made sure there
were cupcakes
now i'm off of cupcakes this is the
sugar house